le 10 décembre dernier au pic de la
crise de la colère comme vous avez pu le
dire et face aux français emmanuel
macron a avancé deux propositions la
première c'était un paquet de mesures
d'urgence et la seconde c'était ce grand
débat national
le paquet de mesures d'urgence nous
l'avons en un record de temps voter nous
l'avons voté confort nous l'avions voter
sans enthousiasme et nous l'avions voté
avec un sens aigu de la responsabilité
sans enthousiasme parce que nous savions
bien nous savions bien qu'une sortie de
kane ne pouvait s'opérer uniquement par
la voie traditionnelle rituel des
concessions financières massives payé
par toujours plus endettement nous
savions bien que ce mouvement traduisait
et au départ à ses origines fortement
soutenu par les français
nous avions bien que ce mouvement
traduisait beaucoup plus qu'une demande
de simples améliorations de l'ordinaire
parce que ce qui était en cause
c'étaient les perspectives d'existence
de chacun et le destin de tous mes chers
collègues mais nous l'avons voté nous
l'avons voté avec le sens de la
responsabilité
parce qu'alors la république était
fragilisée parce qu'alors la nation
était profondément divisée et l'est
toujours et ce sera le prochain est le
principal défi des mois à venir
la seconde proposition c'était le grand
débat j'aurais simplement observer que
je le premier ministre l'exercice
d'aujourd'hui est un peu vain nous ne
votons sur rien et vous ne l'avez pas
proposé de solution puisque vous
attendez les solutions de jupiter je
vous plains d'ailleurs puisque vous êtes
à la troisième séquence depuis lundi de
restitution en revanche parce que nous
avons eu ce sens de la responsabilité ne
nous croyons autorisé à porter une
appréciation juste équilibré sur le
grand débat pour porter cette
appréciation
il faut répondre à deux promesses pour
savoir s'il a rempli justement ses
promesses à deux questions
hier était ce vraiment un grand débat ce
débat était utile grand et ensuite
était-il un vrai débat etait-il grand
500000 contribution mais certaines
copier coller ça n'est pas rien mais ce
n'est pas tout ce sont des contributions
deux français et non pas la contribution
deux français bien moins que 1 % du
corps électoral français
était ce un vrai débat sans doute ya eu
des échanges nombreux des dialogues
nombreux mais trop souvent le dialogue
en tout cas la restitution médiatique de
ce dialogue a tourné au monologue
président de la république a très vite
en quelque sorte consistait monopolisé
la parole au point qu'il semblait dire
que le débat s'était lui lui seul
tombant dans une ornière qu'il avait
déjà précipité dans les difficultés face
à ce mouvement spontané des français de
ce constat je pense qu'on peut déjà
tirer une conclusion en matière
démocratique sur la démocratie
participative
évidemment la démocratie participative
elle est intéressante
mes chers collègues mais ça n'est pas
l'essentiel pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que la démocratie participative
fait entendre des paroles mais pas
toutes les paroles et ensuite parce que
la démocratie participative
elle ne crée pas les conditions d'une
parfaite égalité parce que il y a des
paroles qui porte plus que d'autres
parce que certains certaines minorités
manie mieux la parole que d'autres
évidemment seul le suffrage réalise
l'égalité un homme une femme une voix
bien évidemment général de gaulle avait
pour habitude de dire que la parole du
peuple c'est la parole du peuple
souverain
celle qui était en france trop souvent
contournées du référendum de 2005
constitutionnel jusqu'à celui
consultation publique certes de notre
dame des landes et monsieur le premier
ministre
ma conviction c'est que vous ne soit n'y
aurait pas la blessure à la souveraineté
populaire
simplement avec des groupes de parole il
faudra beaucoup plus parce que ce qui
est en cause bien sûr c'est le pouvoir
d'achat mais au delà du pouvoir d'achat
mes chers collègues
c'est le pouvoir tout court le pouvoir
de chaque français et du peuple français
de peser de maîtriser sa destinée et son
destin c'est la grande question
démocratique et je pense avec beaucoup
d'autres que vous ne pourrez sortir de
ce grand malaise sans une consultation
nationale
je voudrais simplement faire quelques
remarques
la première c'est que prendre les
institutions de la vème république comme
la victime émissaire ce serait trop
commode
vous savez au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle que nous avons pour un
certain nombre vécu plus ou moins bien
d'ailleurs les extrêmes ont fait 45 %
des voix en italie ils ont fait à peine
45 % des voix vous voyez les résultats
la france est gouvernable l'italie
difficilement la stabilité une
démocratie gouverner c'est un bien
public important
alors de grâce pour vos sauver
momentanément touchée avec parcimonie
aux institutions françaises
sur ce moment démocratique bien sûr bien
sûr il faudra recourir au référendum
je suis nous sommes opposés au riz qui
serait la démocratie de lestrem la
démocratie radicale et c'est pas moi qui
donnerait raison à robespierre lorsque
le 16 janvier 1793 il disait que le mot
de représentants de représentation ne
peut s'appliquer à aucun mandataire du
pape parce que la volonté générale ne se
représente pas ça n'est pas moi qui le
dirait évidemment je préfère aussi
tocqueville à monsieur drouet même
lorsqu ils campent devant les portes du
sénat mes chers collègues évidemment
mais pour ce qui concerne le référendum
bien sûr nous devrons y avoir plus
fréquemment recours c'est une évidence
lorsque l'on est notamment gaullistes on
se souvient de l'article 3 de la
constitution de la france qui stipule
évidemment notre constitution que la
souveraineté nationale et bien c'est
elle s'exerce par la voix bien sûr des
représentants du peuple mais aussi par
la voie du référendum
il faut recourir de temps en temps à la
démocratie directe
y'a pas de d'opposition de contradiction
entre une démocratie représentative est
une démocratie directe
bien évidemment donc il faudra en
quelque sorte un moment ou un autre que
vous sachiez rendre la parole aux
français
mais ce ne sera pas suffisant si bien
sûr c'est nécessaire parce que ce
qu'attendent les français ce qu'ils
veulent entendre les français
c'est une parole de vérité et mon propos
aura un écho finalement par rapport à
celui de claude malhuret
je pense moi aussi que ce malaise est
une accumulation de malaise parfois
anciens mais vous ne pouvez pas le
président de la république ne peut pas
s'extraire de sa propre responsabilité
vous entendez dire que les élus les
fonctionnaires la démocratie fonctionne
mal j'ai beaucoup entendu aussi la
remise en question du président de
république qui en parle dans la
restitution en réalité de cette remise
en cause de cette remise en question
[Applaudissements]
mais ce malaise il aa glutineux tant de
faux fuyants tant de faux semblants tant
de mensonges parce que oui on a menti
aux français
lorsque on a voulu leur faire croire que
en travaillant moins
il pourrait améliorer leur sort
augmenter leur niveau de vie et
préserver un modèle social extrêmement
exigeant oui on a menti mes chers
collègues on a menti aux français
lorsque on a confondu
on leur a dit le niveau de la dépense
publique c'est le niveau de qualité des
services publics bien sûr y'a rien de
plus faux parce que si c'est cette
exacte mais nous serions un vrai paradis
pour les services publics mes chers
collègues champion du monde de la
dépense publique est ce que l'hôpital ne
serait pas saturé est ce que la médecine
de proximité ne serait pas fragiliser
est-ce que l'école elle aussi ne serait
pas profondément ébranlée elle qui
reproduit désormais temps de
d'inégalités par rapport à la condition
sociale des familles et des enfants
alors oui bien sûr il faut refermer très
vite ce grand débat le grand débat assez
duré et le temps des décisions mes chers
collègues est enfin arrivé mais il n'y
aura pas de sortie de crise sans un
langage de vérité vérité sur
l'amélioration des conditions des
français ce qui s'est noué cette
angoisse du déclassement vis-à-vis des
classes moyennes oublier trop souvent
avec un tout petit nombre des heureux de
la mondialisation que vous avez trop
souvent survalorisé et le trop grand
nombre des pauvres et des exclus qui
bénéficiaient d'attention mais d'une
attention et inefficace parce que
c'était une attention réduite aux
acquêts caritatif trop souvent la classe
moyenne s'est sentie broyer elle s'est
sentie déclassé pour elle même pour ses
propres enfants
l'ascenseur social absolument bloquer
pendant les trente glorieuses
il fallait trois générations à une
famille modeste pour atteindre le niveau
moyen
il en faut désormais 6 est-ce qu'on peut
s'en contenter
c'est là le vrai problème cette vérité
cette vérité que nous appelons
consistera à dire
qui faut le courage le courage
d'affirmer de dire aux français que
l'économie notre économie nos
entreprises ne crée pas suffisamment de
richesses parce qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de compétitivité pour
améliorer durablement le niveau de vie
des français parce que nous devrons leur
dire qu'il faudra mettre plus de travail
sur la table si nous voulons préserver
un modèle social auquel nous tenons
vous devriez avoir un langage de vérité
pour dire aux français écouter ou alors
nous faisons ce que vous êtes en train
de faire actuellement un modèle anglo
saxon un filet de sécurité pour les plus
pauvres et les classes moyennes vous
vous débrouillez les notamment les
retraités long très bien vu l'approuvent
rice mans mais évidemment on ne peut pas
si on veut garder ce modèle social dire
aux retraités
mais on vous garantit vos pensions mais
surtout on ne touchera pas madame la
ministre
à l'âge légal de départ vous aviez
réseau le sénat une raison sur ce point
là ici évidemment un langage de vérité
un langage de vérité aussi sur les
impôts évidemment taxez moi et vous avez
reconnu qu'il faut taxer mois il a fallu
28 une semaine de manifestations
des centaines d'heures de débats pour se
dire mince la france payent trop
d'impôts
et oui mais il ne suffira pas de dire
que la france les français payent trop
d'impôts il va falloir dire maintenant
quelles sont les dépenses publiques
qu'il faut baisser parce qu'il n'y aura
pas de baisse de la fiscalité s'il n'ya
pas demain de baisse de la dépense
publique et déjà vous avez renoncé
monsieur le ministre
dans la trajectoire a rééquilibré en
les comptes publics donc vous avez cités
sur la dépense publique quoique la
communication parfois habile des uns ou
des autres puissent être sur les
plateaux ou devant des micros bien
évidemment la vérité et sur l'aspect
écologique et climatique parce que c'est
une demande
je me suis souvent trouvé devant des
étudiants devant des jeunes et on sait
bien que cette urgence climatique
ils la partagent encore plus que nous
c'est normal leur avenir est plus long
que le nôtre vraisembablement mais de
grâce quittons cette idée que une
politique énergétique ou écologiques
climatiques ce serait un mélange
bush de leçons de morale et de fiscalité
sa non les français n'en peuvent plus
oui un effort de recherche massif au
niveau européen oui une protection une
taxe écologique aux frontières de
l'europe c'est ce que nous allons
proposer
oui la confiance dans les territoires
c'est fondamental et un mot un dernier
mot bien sûr sur un sujet que vous avez
évoqué la vérité aussi pour les
territoires monsieur le premier ministre
c'est paradoxal parce que vous avez été
maire mais vos propos sont trop
statistiques
je ne me reconnais pas dans les propos
que vous avez tenus ici sur les
territoires est vraiment du siège le
compromettre vais très momentanément
vous devriez passer quelques jours au
côté du président gérard larcher
vous dites jamais il ya eu autant de
moyens pour les collectivités jamais
elles ont bénéficié d'autant d'argent
mais monsieur le premier ministre jamais
les maires n'ont été autant décourager
comment l'expliquez vous jamais jamais
les collectivités jamais les
collectivités n'ont pour les compétences
qui leur ont été attribuées disposer
d'eau si peu de moyens
jamais jamais en france il ya eu une
révision si autoritaire des structures
territoriales le grand roman brement est
ce que je prétends ce que j'ai prétend
vous avez parlé de l'éloignement et bien
je reprends à mon compte voter oui je
coûtais je vous écoute et donc je
reprends le terme l'éloignement et bien
nous avons créé la société de
l'éloignement la société territoria du
loup hahn ans et je voudrais vous
montrer comment est-ce que le ce qui
s'est aussi articulé et nous et le
malaise social territorial et
démocratique s'est finalement jouée le
lieu c'est le lien je sais que le
progressisme pour le progressisme
l'enracinement c'est un obstacle au
changement
sauf que le lieu c'est l'enracinement
dans une communauté humaine où on va
créer du lien on le sait ça confusément
mais on le sait lorsqu'on était élu
local
sauf que la société d'éloignement qu'on
a créé ces des régions toujours plus
grande des cantons toujours plus grand
des communes toujours plus grande des
intercommunalités jour plus grande
et en étirant mes chers collègues de
droite et de gauche on doit pouvoir le
partager quand même nous sommes le sénat
de la république eh bien nous avons
tellement est tiré ce lien géographique
que nous avons brisé le lien civique
parce que nous avons voulu la loi du
nombre au lieu de la loi humaine
je me souviens dans un bon ouvrage que
je vous conseille bernanos lorsqu'il
disait dans la france contre les robots
un monde mes chers collègues un monde
gouverné par la loi du plus fort c'est
un monde vraiment abominable mais un
monde gouverné par la loi du nom c'est
un monde ignoble et bien nous y sommes
la loi du nombre n'est pas la loi des
hommes et entre la distance et la
confiance
il y à une loi inversement proportionnel
lorsque vous êtes loin vous perdez la
confiance lorsque vous êtes dans la
proximité
vous gagnez la confiance c'est ce qui
explique que les maires plus que les
sénateurs plus que le premier ministre
plus que présent république ont encore
la confiance des français donc il va
falloir il va falloir en tirer les
conséquences
toutes les conséquences radicales sur la
décentralisation sur les compétences sur
les niveaux de subsidiarité mais aussi
sur l'action de l'état cassez nous ces
grandes administrations régionales que
je connais parfaitement
ils sont reconcentrés sur les
administrations centrales je pourrais
vous en parler pendant des heures à
mener l'action de l'état dans la
proximité dans les départements ne
pensez pas d'un côté la décentralisation
sans passer de l'autre
l'action territoriale de l'état je vais
terminer je fais abrégé votre souffrance
monsieur le premier je vais conclure
dans quelques jours et sont le manque le
président de la république prendra la
parole parlera-t-il bien sans doute nous
lui reconnaissons talent oratoire parole
parlera-t-il longtemps peut-être nous
lui reconnaissons une forme de
résistance mais partira-t-il claire
parlera-t-il vrai sans courage de dire
il n'y a pas de courage de faire je
pense que les français en ont marre des
subtilités des habilités des ruses du en
même temps d'une pensée complexe ce que
veulent les français
ce n'est pas une complexité c'est la
clarté vis-à-vis d'une vision de
l'avenir c'est non pas la complexité
d'une pensée c'est la simplicité tout
simplement des convictions
alors vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'espérance et bien moi ce que je
propose fermé vite le grand débat pour
ouvrir ouvrir un vrai chemin le vrai
chemin de l'espérance pour la france
c'est celui de la vérité pour tous les
français si vous avez cette audace je
vous assure vous trouverez ici auprès de
nos collègues concluent à léran mon cher
monsieur le président et auprès du
président du sénat vous trouverez
l'appui nécessaire pour relever la
france et pour redonner aux français
bien sûr la confiance et cette espérance
au nom de la république et au nom de la
france